This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. The Brutalist is a movie. I don't know if it's a good movie or a bad movie, but it is definitely the most movie I've seen this year. It is also a movie nominally about architecture and is nominated for 10 Academy Awards. So it felt like journalistic malpractice if we didn't talk about it on the show at least a little bit. The story follows a fictional Hungarian architect named László Tóth and his struggles to build a community center in rural Pennsylvania. The film neatly summarizes the debate about the architectural style known as brutalism in this one exchange.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯。《粗野主义者》是一部电影。我不知道它是一部好电影还是一部烂电影，但它绝对是我今年看过最“电影”的电影。这也是一部名义上关于建筑的电影，获得了 10 项奥斯卡提名。所以如果我们不在节目里稍微讨论一下，就感觉像是违反了新闻职业道德。故事讲述了一个虚构的匈牙利建筑师拉兹洛·托思，以及他在宾夕法尼亚州乡村建造社区中心的挣扎。这部电影通过这段对话，精辟地总结了关于被称为粗野主义的建筑风格的争论。
Concrete is sturdy and cheap. Concrete is not very attractive. The job of architect has often been depicted in movies, even though the practice of architecture is not very cinematic. It's mostly meetings and such. But it is a romantic profession that lends itself to high drama and strained metaphors, which, after seeing the Brutalist, is why I wanted to talk to Mark Lamster. Mark is the architecture critic of the Dallas Morning News, editor of a book called Architecture and Film, and he teaches
混凝土坚固且便宜。混凝土不是很吸引人。电影中经常描绘建筑师的工作，尽管建筑实践本身并不是很有电影感。它主要由会议之类的事情组成。但这是一份浪漫的职业，容易产生戏剧高潮和牵强的隐喻，这就是为什么在看过《粗野主义者》之后，我想和马克·拉姆斯特聊聊。马克是《达拉斯晨报》的建筑评论员，也是一本名为《建筑与电影》的书的编辑，他还教授
an architecture on screen course at Harvard's Graduate School of Design. So he's basically the first and only call you make when you wanna talk about this stuff. Mark, thank you so much for joining us. It's super fun to be here. Thanks for having me. And you have seen the movie, The Brutalist. I have heard you talk about it.
哈佛大学设计研究生院的银幕建筑课程。所以当你想要讨论这些事情时，他基本上是你的第一通也是唯一一通电话。马克，非常感谢你加入我们。很高兴能来到这里。谢谢邀请我。你已经看过电影《粗野主义者》了。我听你谈论过它。
Yes, I have definitely seen the movie, The Brutalist. I have podcasted about it. I wrote a review of it for our newspaper. So yes. So let's talk a little bit just about brutalism in general and why you think that this is the style that this character is working in. How does brutalism fit into this? That's a great question.
是的，我绝对看过电影《粗野主义者》。我为此做过播客。我为我们的报纸写了它的评论。所以是的。那么我们来简单聊聊粗野主义，以及你为什么认为这是这个角色所从事的风格。粗野主义是如何融入其中的？这是一个好问题。
I'm not really sure that it does. When we first meet Laszlo Toth, lead character of The Brutalist, he is really designing in an international style way. He's just come over. He's doing this bent tube furniture, kind of very Marcel Breuer inspired. The next thing we see that he designs is this library, but that's more kind of a modern project. It is the appropriate time, mostly for brutalism. It's a little early for brutalism. If you're, you know, architectural historian looking at moments of history,
我其实不太确定它是否融入其中。当我们第一次见到《粗野主义者》的主角拉斯zlo·托思时，他实际上是在以一种国际主义风格进行设计。他刚来到这里。他在做这种弯曲管状家具，某种程度上受马塞尔·布鲁尔的启发。我们接下来看到他设计的是这个图书馆，但这更像是一个现代主义项目。这是合适的时期，主要是对粗野主义而言。对于粗野主义来说有点早。如果你是一个（你知道的）研究历史时刻的建筑历史学家，
it's a little earlier than brutalism might begin. I mean, I have a contention that what it has to do with brutalism is that the word brutalist is just great. Yes, it is a great word. And unfortunately, it has become sort of the, I think for much of the public, it has become like sort of default word for just all modern architecture,
它比粗野主义开始的时间要早一点。我的意思是，我有一个观点，它与粗野主义有关的地方在于，“粗野主义”（brutalist）这个词太棒了。是的，这是一个伟大的词。不幸的是，它已经变成了一种……我认为对于广大公众来说，它已经变成了所有现代建筑的默认词汇，
which is completely inappropriate, but and it's sort of a cross that we architecture critics and architects themselves have to bear to explain this fact that no brutalism is actually this type of architecture that's really constrained to this relatively short period of time, but you know, in the mind of the general public, any building that they don't like is brutalism. Yeah.
这完全是不恰当的，但这可以说是我们建筑评论员和建筑师本人不得不承受的十字架，去解释这样一个事实：不，粗野主义其实是这种真正局限于相对较短时期的建筑类型，但你知道，在广大公众心目中，他们不喜欢任何建筑都是粗野主义。是的。
So the director of the Brutalist has mentioned that Laszlo Toth, the lead character, is this amalgam of maybe a little Paul Rudolph and Mies van der Rohe and Marcel Breuer. I mean, were you thinking about this at the time you were watching it? The main thing I kept thinking about as I was watching it was that this émigré who had, you know, ostensibly been the leading
所以《粗野主义者》的导演提到，主角拉斯zlo·托思是保罗·鲁道夫、密斯·凡·德罗和马塞尔·布鲁尔的结合体。我的意思是，你在观看的时候有想过这些吗？我在观看时一直在想的一件事是，这个移民本该是匈牙利领先的
modernist architect of Hungary, was thrust into abject poverty in America with no connections. And all I could think about was that Philadelphia at that time where he moves to had this very significant emigre community of architects. The most notable modernist firm there was Howe and Lascaz. They'd built the PSFS tower, which if you've taken an architectural history modernism survey, you've seen it, it was the first modernist skyscraper.
现代主义建筑师，却被推入了美国赤贫的境地，没有任何人脉。我能想到的就是他搬到的那时的费城，有着非常重要的移民建筑师社团。那里最著名的现代主义事务所是豪和拉斯卡兹。他们建造了 PSFS 大厦，如果你上过建筑历史现代主义概论课，你一定见过它，它是第一座现代主义摩天大楼。
So that was built in the 30s in Philadelphia. So the idea that Laszlo Toth comes there, can't find work, is like this unicorn modernist in a city where that is an apostasy. I kept just sitting there and sitting there and sitting there and sitting there because this movie is like three and a half very long hours. Just wondering why he wasn't getting a job or going out and hanging out
所以那是 30 年代在费城建造的。所以拉斯zlo·托思来到这里，找不到工作，就像一个生活在一个将现代主义视为背叛的城市的现代主义独角兽。我坐在那里，坐着，坐着，坐着，因为这部电影长达三个半小时非常漫长。只是在想为什么他没有得到工作，或者出去闲逛
with all these cool modern architects who, you know, live down the block. That's a good point. Did you think about his buildings as an architecture critic at all? Did you like look at them and judge them in a certain way? Well, I'm not really sure what to say about him as an architect per se, because we see
和所有这些很酷的现代建筑师在一起，你知道，他们就住在街区的那头。这倒是个好点子。作为一名建筑评论员，你有没有想过他的建筑？你会不会看着它们并以某种方式评判它们？嗯，我其实不知道该怎么评价他作为一个建筑师本身，因为我们看到
very little of his actual built architecture until the very end of the film. The first thing we see is this library that he's designed, and it's very beautiful as an object, but the only piece of furniture in the library is this, you know, Corbusier style lounge chair. And it just struck me as like, so frigid and uncomfortable for a library. And, you know, I live not far from the actual house that Walter Gropius built for himself here outside of Boston. And it's exactly the opposite kind of space. It's very comfortable and luxurious. And the idea that the only kind of modernist library would be this spare frigid place, I think,
他实际建造的建筑非常少，直到电影快结束时。我们看到的第一件事是他设计的这个图书馆，作为一个物体它非常漂亮，但图书馆里唯一的家具是这个（你知道的）柯布西耶风格的躺椅。这让我觉得，对于一个图书馆来说是如此冰冷和不舒服。而且，你知道，我住的地方离沃尔特·格罗皮乌斯为自己建的房子不远，就在波士顿郊外。那是完全相反的一种空间。非常舒适和豪华。而唯一一种现代主义图书馆竟然是这种简陋冰冷的地方的想法，我认为
didn't line up for me with history. It looked nice on screen, right? But it wasn't the kind of place that you'd want to actually read a book. Yeah, I think most of the depictions of architecture and design in the movie are all about, you know, what looks good to be filmed or photographed and what serves the story. And they're not really about the veracity of different movements and such like that. I think if the movie wasn't about architecture itself, there would be a lot easier to forgive
这与历史不符。它在银幕上看起来不错，对吧？但它不是那种你真的想去那儿读本书的地方。是的，我认为电影中对建筑和设计的大多数描绘，都是为了迎合拍摄或摄影的好看，以及为剧情服务。它们并不是关于不同运动的真实性之类的事情。我想如果这部电影不是关于建筑本身的，就会容易得多去原谅
the transgressions, shall we say. But I mean, you asked about like his actual architecture, really the only time we really encounter his full architecture is, you know, at the end when we're presented with this community center that the community actually didn't ask for. So let's talk about architecture in movies in general. I mean, you edited a book on architecture in film and thought about this a lot. What are architects in movies for? They seem like they have different purpose than your average vocation as depicted on
这些违背常理之处，我们可以这么说。但我的意思是，你问到关于他实际建筑的问题，实际上我们真正接触到他完整建筑的唯一一次，（你知道的）是在最后，我们看到了这个社区中心，而这个社区甚至并没有要求建造它。所以我们来谈谈电影中的建筑。我的意思是，你编辑过一本关于电影中建筑的书，也对此深思熟虑过。电影中的建筑是用来做什么的？它们似乎有着与银幕上描绘的普通职业不同的目的。
screen. Absolutely. Well, first of all, there are very few films that are about actual architects that center on the practice of making architecture. And it's kind of easy to understand why. And it's because architecture is kind of boring. It takes a long time to make. It's, you know, a lot of plumbing details. It's a lot of plumbing details. It's a lot of going over plans. No one dies. There's no spying.
绝对是的。首先，很少有电影是关于实际建筑师的，或者以建造建筑的实践为中心的。这其实很容易理解。这是因为建筑有点无聊。建造需要很长时间。它包含（你知道的）很多管道细节。有很多管道细节。有很多审阅图纸。没有人死。没有间谍活动。
There are no superheroes involved, right? So it doesn't easily fit into the standard narrative structures of Hollywood film that require the sort of incredible existential drama, right? Architecture is kind of like oxygen, you know? It's all around us, we can't live without it, but we also take it super for granted, right? So when architects do appear in films,
没有超级英雄参与，对吧？所以它不容易契合好莱坞电影的标准叙事结构，因为后者需要那种不可思议的存在主义戏剧性，对吧？建筑有点像氧气，你知道的？它无处不在，我们离不开它，但我们也认为这是理所当然的，对吧？所以当建筑师出现在电影中时，
usually they're there as a signpost of sort of bourgeois respectability. He is both, it's usually a man, not always, but quite often, and he is both an artist and a respected professional, right? So he is this ideal figure, very attractive. I think of the character Sam Waterston plays in Hannah and Her Sisters, right? I really came in here because I was bored stiff by the party. What makes you think we're more interesting? And he's this very urbane, has a box at the opera, is able to discourse on all of the arts. The design's deliberately non-contextual, but I wanted, discourse on all of the arts. The design's deliberately non-contextual,
通常他们是作为资产阶级尊严的标志出现的。他既是，通常是个男人，虽然并非总是如此，但经常如此，他既是一位艺术家，又是一个受人尊敬的专业人士，对吧？所以他是一个理想的人物，非常有吸引力。我想到了萨姆·沃特斯顿在《汉娜姐妹》中扮演的角色，对吧？我来这里是因为我被派对无聊透顶了。你凭什么认为我们更有趣？他非常温文尔雅，在歌剧院有包厢，能够对所有艺术侃侃而谈。这个设计故意不追求语境，但我希望，对所有艺术侃侃而谈。这个设计故意不追求语境，
but I wanted to keep the atmosphere of the street, you know, in the proportions and in the material that's unpolished red granite. He's very successful as a Mercedes. And, you know, in the film, we see characters played by Diane Weist and Carrie Fisher just thawning over them. It's like, which one of them will get to bed,
但我希望保留街道的氛围，你知道的，在比例和材质上，那是未抛光的红花岗岩。他作为一个梅赛德斯非常成功。而且，你知道，在电影中，我们看到黛安·韦斯特和凯丽·费舍尔扮演的角色对他垂涎三尺。就像，她们谁能把这个男人弄上床，
this man is the principal action around his character. Of course I was so tongue-tied all night. I can't believe I said that about the Guggenheim. That is like, we often see that. It's like this architect is this, a signpost rather than an actual, you know, than his career actually described, you know, in any number of films, you will see this from, you know,
这个男人的主要行动都围绕着他的角色展开。当然我整晚都结结巴巴的。我不敢相信我对古根海姆说的那样的话。这就像，我们经常看到这种情况。就像这个建筑师是一个标志，而不是一个实际的（你知道的）他的职业在任何数量的电影中被实际描述，（你知道的）从
Jungle Fever, the Spike Lee film, Sleepless in Seattle, you know, you could just go through Hollywood and that's sort of the idealized vision of the architect as professional and artist at once very desirable. I mean, the architect is essentially just this artist that just has his stuff together enough to pay a mortgage. And a BMW, right, exactly.
《丛林热》（斯派克·李的电影）、《西雅图夜未眠》，（你知道的）你可以看看好莱坞，这就是那种将建筑师理想化为专业人士和艺术家的形象，同时又极具吸引力。我的意思是，建筑师本质上只是一个勉强把事情处理好到足以付得起房贷的艺术家。还有一辆宝马，对吧，完全正确。
So like an older woman can like go like, okay, I'm not like throwing my life away for this guy. Yeah, yeah. Exactly. Yeah. So funny. Sort of the ground zero for architects depicted on film is Howard Rourke in The Fountainhead. This is an awful, awful movie. Well, it's both a great movie and a terrible movie, right? So 1949, The Fountainhead, based on the novel by Ayn Rand and directed by King Vidor. And the characters in the film are, of course, generally just mouthpieces for her objectivist ideology, basically libertarianist thinking.
所以年长的女性可以这样说：好吧，我没有为了这个家伙浪费我的人生。是的，是的。完全正确。哈哈，太有趣了。电影中描绘建筑师的零点是《源泉》中的霍华德·洛克。这是一部糟糕透顶的电影。嗯，它既是一部伟大的电影，也是一部糟糕的电影，对吧？所以 1949 年的《源泉》，根据安·兰德的小说改编，金·维多执导。电影中的角色当然通常只是她客观主义意识形态的传声筒，基本上是自由意志主义思想。
They hate you for the greatness of your achievement. They hate you for your integrity. They hate you because they know they can either corrupt you nor rule you. And the lead character in the film, played by Gary Cooper, is this architect named Howard Rourke, and he's a very dogmatic modernist. He does not want his vision corrupted.
他们恨你成就的伟大。他们恨你的正直。他们恨你，因为他们知道他们既不能腐蚀你，也不能统治你。片中的主角由加里·库珀饰演，是一个名叫霍华德·洛克的建筑师，他是一个非常教条的现代主义者。他不想让自己的愿景被玷污。
You know, we see him heroically at the beginning of the film getting this incredible commission for a skyscraper and when the conservative bankers who he presents his model to see his modern building, they want to attack on this sort of classical facade on the front and he is aghast and refuses this and storms out because no one shall interfere with his genius. It has shocked people. It's too different, too original. Why take chances when you can stay in the middle?
你知道的，我们在电影开头看到他英雄般地得到了一个令人难以置信的摩天大楼委托，当他向保守的银行家展示他的模型时，他们看到了他的现代建筑，他们想在前面加上这种古典立面，他大惊失色并拒绝了这一点，然后冲了出去，因为没有人可以干涉他的天才。这震惊了人们。太不同了，太原创了。既然可以待在中间，为什么还要冒险？
If you want my work, you must take it as it is or not at all. We are your clients and it's your job to serve us. I don't build in order to have clients. I have clients in order to build. Of course, the film sort of culminates with this incredible scene where he has now designed a housing project and once again its completion has escaped his control and his solution to this is to just go and blow up
如果你想要我的作品，你必须全盘接受，否则就免谈。我们是你的客户，为你服务是你的工作。我不是为了有客户而建造。我有客户是为了建造。当然，电影以这样一个不可思议的场景达到高潮：他现在设计了一个住宅项目，而它的完成再次脱离了他的控制，他对此的解决办法就是去炸毁
the housing project. housing project. And of course, today this sounds like domestic terrorism, but in the world of the film, it's this act of completely justified, righteous behavior, and he's in fact gets off at this trial that's held because no one in the world of Ayn Rand should interfere with the individual heroic genius. This idea of this architect who no one should confront his vision, he's a sole male genius, it basically holds even through today. I think The Brutalist is very much a product of that same vision.
这个住宅项目。住宅项目。当然，在今天这听起来像国内恐怖主义，但在电影的世界里，这是一种完全合理、正义的行为，事实上他在随后的审判中被无罪释放，因为在安·兰德的世界里，没有人应该干涉个人的英雄天才。这种认为建筑师的愿景不容任何人质疑、他是唯一的男性天才的想法，基本上一直延续到今天。《粗野主义者》在很大程度上也是这种相同愿景的产物。
We also have, you know, the character here, played by Adrian Brody, also sort of refuses to have his work corrupted in any way to the extent that he will pay for all change orders and overruns on its cause. He cuts three meters from the top, I added to the bottom. We can't afford all this. I'm already over budget this quarter. You take what you need from my feed, Ashley. Come on, what's the difference between 40 and 50 feet anyway? The ceiling's still plenty high.
我们还有（你知道的）这里的角色，由阿德里安·布罗迪饰演，也某种程度上拒绝让他的作品受到任何形式的玷污，甚至不惜自己支付所有变更订单和超支费用。他从顶部削减了三米，我加到底部。我们负担不起这一切。我这季度已经超预算了。你从我的费用里拿你需要的部分，阿什利。得了吧，40英尺和50英尺到底有什么区别？天花板依然很高。
Good, it's approved. Several of the scenes in The Brutalist are even borrowed, you know, directly from the fountainhead, these scenes in quarries and what have you. Architecture is really a collaborative art practiced by many people working together over long periods of time. So I think in many ways, this is sort of very dated way
很好，批准了。《粗野主义者》中的几个场景甚至是（你知道的）直接借鉴自《源泉》，比如采石场的这些场景等等。建筑实际上是一门协作的艺术，由许多人在很长一段时间内共同实践。所以我认为在很多方面，这是一种非常过时的
of thinking about the profession. Are there some examples in history of film where architecture is presented in a way that feels true to you? I think the best examples are always going to be documentaries. Two recent ones that I really enjoyed, one, Stardust, which is a film about the careers and lives of Denise Scott Brown and Robert Venturi. And it's really about their partnership,
对这个职业的看法。在电影史上，有没有一些建筑以一种对你来说真实的方式呈现的例子？我认为最好的例子永远是纪录片。我最近非常喜欢的两个，一个是《星尘》，这是一部关于丹妮丝·斯科特·布朗和罗伯特·文图里的职业生涯和生活的电影。它实际上是关于他们的合作伙伴关系，
working together about ideas. Another film I really enjoyed is called We Start With The Things We Find, documentary about the New York-based firm, Low Tech, founded by Neapolitan partners, Adetola and Giuseppe Lignano. And they, what's amazing, I think there's this very comparable scene
共同致力于理念。我非常喜欢的另一部电影叫《我们从我们发现的东西开始》，这是一部关于总部位于纽约的事务所 Low Tech 的纪录片，由那不勒斯合伙人阿德托拉和朱塞佩·利尼亚诺创立。而他们，令人惊叹的是，我认为有一个与《粗野主义者》以及《源泉》非常相似的场景，
to The Brutalist and also to The Fountainhead, right? Where in The Brutalist, we see Laszlo Toth going to this Italian quarry to find the most beautiful marbles for his project. Whereas the film on Lotec starts with the characters also going to Italy, but in fact they're going to a shipyard to look at shipping containers and all this other infrastructural work, which is, you know, the detritus of the world, which, you know, they've decided like we need to
对吧？在《粗野主义者》中，我们看到拉斯zlo·托思去这个意大利采石场为他的项目寻找最美丽的云石。而关于 Lotec 的电影则是从角色也去意大利开始，但实际上他们是去造船厂看集装箱和所有这些其他基础设施工作，你知道的，这是世界的废弃物，你知道的，他们决定：我们需要
recover this and use this and transform the stuff that we might throw away or think of as purely industrial and transform that into architecture. It's a really beautiful idea. It strikes me that another thing that filmmakers use architects for is as a very basic metaphor to directors and filmmakers. Megalopolis, I think, is a movie about filmmaking more than it's about city planning in any sort of meaningful way. In The Brutalist, it kind of blew my mind that the end credit song is this song that says,
恢复这个、利用这个，并将我们可能会扔掉或认为是纯粹工业的东西转化为建筑。这是一个非常美丽的想法。这让我觉得，电影制作人使用建筑师的另一个原因是作为导演和电影制作人的一种非常基础的隐喻。《大都会》在我看来是一部关于电影制作的电影，而不仅仅是关于任何意义上的城市规划。在《粗野主义者》中，让我大吃一惊的是，片尾曲竟然是这首歌，里面唱着：
"'One for me, one for you, one for me, one for you,' which is a movie trope of like, you're gonna make one for the masses or for Hollywood and one of your personal things. This is not a line architects say very much to each other because they're all like for all of us. You know, like there is no one for me.
“一个给我，一个给你，一个给我，一个给你”，这是电影里的一个老套路，就像你要为一个大众或好莱坞拍一部，再拍一部你的个人作品。这不是建筑师们经常互相说的一句话，因为他们都在为我们所有人创作。你知道的，就像没有“一个给我”这种说法。
So what about this is sort of like architecture as ham-fisted metaphor to movie making. Well, I think it's kind of an obvious choice, right? And I saw exactly the same thing when I was looking at both of those films. It strikes me, they're both, stereotypically, the product of this lone male genius who has this vision and sees it to be completed
所以这怎么能算作是建筑对电影制作的笨拙隐喻呢？嗯，我认为这是一个显而易见的选择，对吧？当我看着这两部电影时，我看到了完全相同的事情。在我看来，它们都是（老一套地）这种孤独男性天才的产物，他有这种愿景并看到它得以实现，
as per meeting his genius ideas. Whereas really, they're also, it's this wide cast of craftsmen to create this, an artist working together over a very long period of time. Usually one person gets the credit, but there's innu-, look at the credits to a film, it's like an endless, you know. In the end, you have this sort of three-dimensional
以满足他的天才理念。然而实际上，它们也是由大批工匠来创造的，这是一个艺术家在很长一段时间内共同合作的过程。通常一个人获得了赞誉，但有无数……看看电影的职员表，就像一个无休止的列表，你知道的。最后，你会得到这种三维的
object that you sort of encounter in time and space, right, whether it's a film or a building. So there is like a really interesting analogy there, and I think a lot of filmmakers have seen that over the years. Peter Greenaway and his film, the bellyibel even architect might be an example for that. Obviously both the Brutalist and Megalopolis stand for that. In a way, the fountainhead is very much that for Ayn Rand in a way. But are there actually any works of fiction that get architecture right where you felt like they really nailed it? I think the filmmaker who best got it was Jacques Tati, the French filmmaker, the sort of French chaplain, if you will. And his films Mon Oncle and Playtime, they're really
物体，你在时间和空间中去体验它，对吧，无论是电影还是建筑。所以这里确实有一个非常有趣的类比，我认为多年来很多电影制作人都看到了这一点。彼得·格林纳威和他的电影《建筑师的腹胃》甚至就是一个例子。显然，《粗野主义者》和《大都会》都代表了这一点。在某种程度上，《源泉》对安·兰德来说也是如此。但实际上有没有任何小说作品把建筑写对了，让你觉得他们真正做到了？我认为最懂这一点的电影制作人是雅克·塔蒂，这位法国电影制作人，可以说是法国的卓别林。他的电影《我的叔叔》和《玩乐时间》，实际上是
about a confrontation with traditionalism and modernism and how the modern city shapes who we are and our like very humane look at modern architecture about Americanization of the city the modernization of the city and they look at it critically but also with the sort of humanity and acceptance like we need to accept what is happening and we can make fun of it, but we're going to live in this world
关于对传统主义和现代主义的对抗，以及现代城市如何塑造我们，以及我们对现代建筑非常人道主义的看法——关于城市的美国化、城市的现代化，他们以批判的眼光看待它，但也带着一种人道主义和接纳——我们需要接受正在发生的事情，我们可以取笑它，但无论我们喜欢与否，我们都将生活在这个世界上
whether we like it or not. Before we go, are there any other fictional architects that you wanna talk about? Well, we haven't talked about America's most famous screen architect. Who would that be? Well, Mike Brady, of course. That's right, Mike Brady.
在我们离开之前，还有其他你想谈论的虚构建筑师吗？嗯，我们还没谈到美国最著名的银幕建筑师。会是谁呢？嗯，迈克·布雷迪，当然。没错，迈克·布雷迪。
So tell me about Mike Brady and how he practices architecture. Well, I think, you know, I'm guessing that for many of the listeners out there who are aged age. Mike Brady is their most common architect. He's not a very good architect. He lives in this very dated, kitschy ranch burger with a sunken living room. Of course, the very dramatic open staircase. And I find that there aren't too many episodes of the Brady Bunch where we see
所以跟我讲讲迈克·布雷迪以及他是如何从事建筑的。嗯，我想，（你知道的）我猜对于许多到了一定年龄的听众来说，迈克·布雷迪是他们最熟悉的建筑师。他不是一个非常好的建筑师。他住在这种非常过时、流于俗套的牧场风格住宅里，带下沉式客厅。当然还有非常戏剧性的开敞式楼梯。我发现《布雷迪部族》中没有太多集能让我们看到
Mike actually engaging in architecture, but there is one that I find incredibly interesting. It's an episode called Mike's Horror Scope. And in this episode, Mike is approached by this quasi-Italian fashion impresario named Bibi Gallini, and she is very fabulous. I would introduce myself, but everyone knows who Bibi Gallini is. Even people on the street come up to me and say, it's Bibi. And I always say to them, hello, my darling.
迈克真正参与建筑，但有一集我觉得非常有趣。这一集叫《迈克的恐怖望远镜》。在这一集中，一个名叫比比·加利尼的准意大利时尚大亨找到了迈克，她非常了不起。我要自我介绍一下，但人人都知道比比·加利尼是谁。甚至街上的人都会走过来对我说，是比比。我总是对他们说，你好，亲爱的。
She wants Mike to design a factory for her, and she gives him this complete freedom to do something creative and inventive. She wants it to be pink and fluffy. Make the factory the shape of a powder puff. Powder puff? Or maybe tall, like a lipstick. Lipstick? A factory has to be practical and efficient.
她想让迈克为她设计一个工厂，并赋予他完全的自由去做一些富有创意和创新性的事情。她希望它是粉红色且毛茸茸的。把工厂设计成粉扑的形状。粉扑？或者也许高高的，像一支口红。口红？工厂必须实用且高效。
And Mike just can't wrap his mind around it. He keeps designing these like very straightforward factories for her and she's like, no no and then she says she wants the roof to open up and he's like that's technically impossible and what's funny to me is that instead of embracing this brief that he's given he could do anything and create some really interesting architecture he's just so straightforward and lacks such an idea of invention that he sort of loses the client. I always find it very sad for Mike. It shows the challenge of the architect, right? Which is like clients are always difficult. You have to figure out how to both satisfy your own vision while satisfying demands. It's such a notable deviation from all the other ones we've discussed, that given complete freedom, he just is like, please just make it a box and put stuff in it.
而迈克就是无法理解这一点。他一直为她设计这种非常直白的工厂，而她却说，不不，然后她说她想要屋顶能够打开，而他却说这在技术上是不可能的。对我来说有趣的是，他没有欣然接受别人给他的这个简报——他本可以做任何事并创造一些非常有趣的建筑，但他实在太死板了，缺乏这种创新意识，以至于他有点失去了这个客户。我总是为迈克感到难过。这展示了建筑师的挑战，对吧？也就是客户总是很难缠。你必须弄清楚如何在满足自己愿景的同时满足各种要求。这与我们讨论过所有其他情况有着明显的不同，鉴于完全的自由，他却只想说：请把它做成一个盒子，然后往里面塞东西。
Well, this has been so fun to talk about, Mark. I really appreciate you coming on the show. It's been a lot of fun. Thanks. You can read Mark Lamster's architecture column in the Dallas Morning News. He also wrote an excellent biography of architect Philip Johnson. It's called The Man in the Glass House. Check it out.
嗯，聊这些太有趣了，马克。非常感谢你来到节目。这真的非常有趣。谢谢。你可以在《达拉斯晨报》上阅读马克·拉姆斯特的建筑专栏。他还写过一本关于建筑师菲利普·约翰逊的优秀传记。书名叫《玻璃屋里的人》。去看看吧。
After the break, Brutalism 101 with Avery Truffleman. And we're back. If you finished The Brutalist and thought, I don't really understand Brutalism, well, we have a story for you. Enjoy. The best James Bond is either Sean Connery or Daniel Craig. I lean towards Daniel Craig. The new movies are just better. But the Sean Connery films definitely had the best villains. There's Blofeld, of course, who's so iconic that he turned the act of cat stroking
休息之后，是艾弗里·特吕夫曼带来的《粗野主义 101》。我们回来了。如果你看完《粗野主义者》后觉得“我其实不太懂粗野主义”，好吧，我们为你准备了一个故事。请欣赏。最好的詹姆斯·邦德要么是肖恩·康纳利，要么是丹尼尔·克雷格。我更倾向于丹尼尔·克雷格。新电影就是更好。但肖恩·康纳利的电影绝对有最好的反派。当然有布洛费德，他标志性到把抚摸猫这个动作
into a thing that super villains do. But Bond's flashiest nemesis has to be Goldfinger. Do you expect me to talk? No, Mr. Bond, I expect you to die. Do you expect me to talk? Yeah, I expect you to talk. There's this dorky fun fact that the Bond villain, Goldfinger, was actually named after a real person.
变成了超级反派都会做的一件事。但邦德最招摇的死敌一定是金手指。你指望我说实话吗？不，邦德先生，我指望你死。你指望我说实话吗？对，我指望你说实话。有一个书呆子式的冷知识，邦德的反派“金手指”其实是以一个真人命名的。
That's Truffleman. Avery Truffleman. The author of the James Bond books, Ian Fleming, named Goldfinger for a man he found so dastardly, so terrible, that he immortalized him in pop culture. The real Goldfinger was an architect, Erno Goldfinger, and he made giant, hulking, austere concrete buildings. Goldfinger's buildings were decreed soulless. Inhabitants claimed to suffer health problems and depression from spending time inside them. Some of Goldfinger's buildings were vacated because occupants found them so ugly.
那是特吕夫曼。艾弗里·特吕夫曼。詹姆斯·邦德小说的作者伊恩·弗莱明以一个他认为如此卑鄙、如此糟糕的人命名了“金手指”，以至于他在流行文化中将他永垂不朽。真正的金手指是一名建筑师，埃尔诺·金手指，他建造了巨大的、笨重的、朴素的混凝土建筑。金手指的建筑被判定为毫无灵魂。居民们声称在其中生活会遭受健康问题和抑郁的困扰。金手指的一些建筑由于居民觉得它们太丑而被空置。
And yet many architects praised Goldfinger's buildings. His Trellick Tower, which was once threatened with demolition, has been awarded landmark status. This divide, this hatred from the public, and love from designers and architects tends to be the narrative around buildings like Goldfinger's, which is to say gigantic, imposing buildings made of concrete.
然而，许多建筑师对金手指的建筑赞不绝口。他的特雷利克塔曾面临被拆除的威胁，如今已被授予地标地位。这种分歧——公众的憎恨与设计师和建筑师的喜爱——往往是围绕像金手指这样的建筑的叙事，也就是说，由混凝土建造的巨大、雄伟的建筑。
What some people refer to as brutalist architecture. And a lot of folks, beyond the creator of James Bond, love to hate them. We are in Worcester Hall, which to my great dismay and frustration, is often considered the worst building on campus, or Worcester Hall, more like worst. I met up with Sarah Briggs-Ramsey in Worcester Hall, a brutalist building at UC Berkeley. I can't tell you how many times I've been locking up my bike outside and I overhear undergrads walking with their parents and going, ironically, this is the architecture school and it's the ugliest building on campus.
也就是有些人所说的粗野主义建筑。除了詹姆斯·邦德的创造者之外，很多人都“爱恨交加”。我们在伍斯特大厅，令我无比沮丧和懊恼的是，它通常被认为是校园里最糟糕的建筑，或者说伍斯特大厅，更像“最差大厅”。我在加州大学伯克利分校的粗野主义建筑伍斯特大厅见到了萨拉·布里格斯-拉姆齐。我无法告诉你，有多少次我在外面锁自行车时，无意中听到本科生和他们的父母走过并讽刺地说：瞧，这是建筑系，它是校园里最丑的建筑。
Yep. Worcester Hall is the architecture school. it's the ugliest building on campus. Yep, Worcester Hall is the architecture school. Sarah completed her masters there. Buildings like this are pretty pervasive across most American and Canadian campuses. Yeah, there was a big, bulky concrete building on the campus where I went to college. And I hated when I had to go through it. It just reminded me of a bunker or a bomb shelter. These big concrete buildings just like bummed me out. Absolutely.
没错。伍斯特大厅就是建筑系。它是校园里最丑的建筑。没错，伍斯特大厅就是建筑系。萨拉在那里完成了她的硕士学位。这样的建筑在大多数美国和加拿大的校园里都相当普遍。是的，我上大学的校园里有一座又大又笨重的混凝土建筑。我讨厌不得不穿过它的时候。它只是让我想起一个地堡或防空洞。这些巨大的混凝土建筑就是让我心情沮丧。绝对是的。
I mean, it has these connotations of, you know, Soviet era construction, sometimes third world construction, all these negative associations. This is Professor Adrian Forti, author of the excellent book, Concrete and Culture. He's been researching concrete for around 10 years now. It has a bad name. Apart from aesthetic criticisms,
我的意思是，它带有（你知道的）苏联时期建筑的内涵，有时是第三世界建筑的内涵，所有这些负面联想。这是阿德里安·福蒂教授，优秀图书《混凝土与文化》的作者。他研究混凝土已经大约 10 年了。它名声不好。除了美学批评之外，
concrete buildings present environmental concerns. A lot of these buildings were built at a time when energy was cheap, and they use up an awful lot of energy to heat and cool them. Concrete buildings were built with the illusion of plenty, that we will always have enough energy to build and heat and cool these massive inefficient structures. As harsh as it looks, concrete is an utterly optimistic building material, arguably too optimistic. Really from the 1920s, it was seen as being a material that would change the world.
混凝土建筑还带来了环境问题。其中许多建筑建造于能源便宜的时期，它们消耗了大量的能量来供暖和制冷。混凝土建筑是在资源充足的幻觉下建造的，认为我们永远会有足够的能源来建造、供暖和冷却这些庞大且低效的结构。尽管它看起来很刺眼，但混凝土是一种极其乐观的建筑材料，可以说过于乐观了。实际上从 20 世纪 20 年代开始，它就被视为一种将改变世界的材料。
It had the potential to build things in a way that hadn't been seen before. Concrete was this material that seemed boundless, readily available in vast quantities, and could create massive spaces unlike any other material. So concrete sprang up everywhere. It's the second most heavily consumed product in the world. The only thing we consume more of than concrete is water. We use concrete for sidewalks, bridges, tunnels and highways. And of course, for giant buildings.
它有潜力以一种前所未见的方式建造东西。混凝土是一种似乎无边无际、随时可大量获得并能创造出无与伦比的巨大空间的材料。因此混凝土处处涌现。它是世界上消费量第二大的产品。我们消耗量仅次于混凝土的东西是水。我们将混凝土用于人行道、桥梁、隧道和高速公路。当然，还有巨大的建筑。
Whether we're talking about stadia or auditoria. Or condominia or gymnasia or planetaria. So historically, government programs all over the world loved concrete. Particularly in Soviet Russia, but also later in Europe, North America. It was used for welfare welfare state projects. Concrete presented the most efficient way to house huge numbers of people. And philosophically, it was seen as humble, capable, and honest. Concrete was just out there in all of its rough glory, not hiding behind any paint or layers, saying, here I am.
无论我们谈论的是体育场还是礼堂。或者公寓楼、体育馆还是天文馆。因此历史上，世界各地的政府项目都对混凝土情有独钟。特别是在苏联俄罗斯，后来也在欧洲、北美。它被用于福利国家项目。混凝土为容纳大量人口提供了最有效的方式。在哲学上，它被视为谦逊、能干和诚实的。混凝土以其粗犷的荣耀展现在那里，不隐藏在任何油漆或涂层后面，仿佛在说：这就是我。
Love me or hate me. And as concrete buildings came to signify humility, honesty, and integrity, they were erected all over the world as housing projects, courthouses, schools, churches, hospitals, and city halls. You'll stand outside, and a tour bus will go by, and there'll be, ladies and gentlemen, voted the most ugliest building in the world,
爱我还是恨我。随着混凝土建筑开始象征着谦逊、诚实和正直，它们作为住宅项目、法院、学校、教堂、医院和市政厅在世界各地拔地而起。你站在外面，一辆观光巴士开过，上面会说：女士们先生们，被评为世界上最丑的建筑，
Boston City Hall. How do you compete with that? Chris Grimley is up against a lot, but he's trying to restore Boston City Hall's reputation. My name is Chris Grimley. I'm with my fellow heroic people, Mark Pasnick and Michael Kubo. Chris, Mark and Michael have embarked on what they call the Heroic Project,
波士顿市政厅。你如何与此竞争？克里斯·格里姆利面临着很多困难，但他正试图恢复波士顿市政厅的名誉。我叫克里斯·格里姆利。我和我英雄般的伙伴们在一起，马克·帕斯尼克和迈克尔·久保。克里斯、马克和迈克尔开启了他们所谓的“英雄项目”，
chronicling the concrete structures in and around Boston. Rather than referring to these concrete buildings as brutalist, they prefer the term heroic, because like so many superheroes, these structures have the best, most noble intentions, but are sorely misunderstood. Also, just generally, brutalism is a big, broad label that gets used inconsistently in architecture. People tend to disagree on one precise definition. The name brutalism also just sounds intense, even though it's not actually related to brutality.
记录波士顿市内及周围的混凝土结构。比起将这些混凝土建筑称为粗野主义，他们更喜欢用“英雄”这个词，因为就像许多超级英雄一样，这些结构有着最好、最高尚的意图，却被严重误解了。另外，总的来说，粗野主义是一个庞大而宽泛的标签，在建筑中被不一致地使用。人们往往对一个精确的定义意见不一。粗野主义这个名字听起来也很强烈，尽管它实际上与野蛮（brutality）无关。
It comes from béton brut, which is a French term for raw concrete. In any case, to these guys, heroic feels like a better term, especially in Boston, where concrete architecture swooped in and saved the day. You have to situate Boston in late 50s, 1960s. It is America's first city. Well, it is America's most historic city. Again, not really, but I get your point. And yet it finds itself in the doldrums. Boston, like a lot of other American cities, was plagued
它来自“béton brut”，这是一个法语词汇，意为清水混凝土。无论如何，对这些人来说，英雄感觉是一个更好的词，尤其是在波士顿，这里的混凝土建筑异军突起并拯救了局面。你必须把波士顿放在 50 年代末、1960 年代的情境中来看。它是美国的第一个城市。好吧，它是美国最具历史意义的城市。再次说明，其实并不是，但我懂你的意思。然而它却发现自己处于低谷。波士顿和许多其他美国城市一样，受到了
by a loss of manufacturing jobs and white flight to the suburbs. And for decades, Boston had the highest property taxes in the nation and almost no development. There is this recognition from civic authorities that something needs to be done, and something needs to be done quickly. So Boston sets an agenda to make the city great again, with big, soaring, capable, thoroughly modern buildings made, of course, out of concrete.
制造业工作流失和白人群飞至郊区的困扰。几十年来，波士顿拥有全美最高的房产税，却几乎没有任何发展。民政当局意识到必须做点什么，而且必须迅速采取行动。因此，波士顿制定了一个让城市再次伟大的议程，建造高耸、有能力、完全现代的建筑，当然，这些建筑是由混凝土制成的。
And though some of these buildings were celebrated, others were really not. What we call the third rail of Boston concrete modernism is City Hall. When Boston City Hall was built in 1968, critics were put off by this concrete style. It was called alienating and cold. And since it was a government building,
尽管其中一些建筑受到了赞誉，但其他一些则绝对没有。我们称之为波士顿混凝土现代主义第三条铁轨的是市政厅。当波士顿市政厅于 1968 年建成时，评论家们对这种混凝土风格感到反感。它被称为疏离和寒冷。由于它是一座政府建筑，
this criticism became impossible to remove from politics. Boston City Hall became a political pawn. Mayors and city council members kept trying to win public support with promises to get rid of the building, like John Tobin did when he ran for city council. Hi everybody, this is John Tobin. Thanks for visiting votejontobin.com. Here we are on City Hall Plaza in front of Boston City Hall. I'm not an architect, but I know bad architecture when I see it.
这种批评就变得无法与政治剥离。波士顿市政厅成了一个政治筹码。市长和市议员们不断试图通过承诺拆除这座建筑来赢得公众支持，就像约翰·托宾竞选市议员时所做的那样。大家好，我是约翰·托宾。感谢访问 votejontobin.com。现在我们在波士顿市政厅广场前，面对波士顿市政厅。我不是建筑师，但我能看出什么是糟糕的建筑。
This is a bad building, and I know bad architecture when I see it. This is a bad building, and I think we can do a lot by knocking this building down. Former Mayor Thomas Menino actually started a study to really look into tearing it down. It turned out as a result of the study that you would need something like a nuclear grade weapon, basically, to destroy this building
这是一座糟糕的建筑，而且我能看出什么是糟糕的建筑。这是一座糟糕的建筑，我认为我们可以通过拆除这座建筑来做很多事情。前市长托马斯·梅尼诺实际上启动了一项研究，以真正调查将其拆除的可行性。结果证明，由于这项研究，你基本上需要某种核武器级别的武器来摧毁这座建筑，
because it's so heavily overbuilt in concrete. And so, when they couldn't tear down City Hall, officials chose to ignore it. People that occupied the building for decades and decades didn't like it, and so they didn't invest money into the building and effectively wanted to see the building go away. This is called active neglect, and it happens with a lot of concrete buildings. They are intentionally unrepaired, unrenovated, and uncared for. Which only makes the building more ugly, and then more hated, and then more ignored, and
因为它的混凝土超建得太严重了。因此，当他们无法拆除市政厅时，官员们选择忽视它。几十年来一直占据这座建筑的人不喜欢它，因此他们没有向这座建筑投资，实际上希望这座建筑消失。这被称为积极忽视，许多混凝土建筑都存在这种情况。它们被故意不加修缮、不作翻新、不予照料。这只会让这座建筑变得更丑，进而更招人恨，进而更被忽视，并且
creates this vicious cycle where the public hate of Boston City Hall feeds itself. And then the discussion years on really became about what the original architects had done wrong, as if this were not a failure of maintenance, but a failure of the initial design. When people built these mammoth concrete structures, no one really thought about maintenance. They seemed indestructible. In the early days of concrete, people assumed that this was an everlasting material
形成了一个恶性循环，公众对波士顿市政厅的憎恨在不断自我滋养。然后多年的讨论实际上变成了原建筑师做错了什么，好像这不是维护的失败，而是最初设计的失败。当人们建造这些庞大的混凝土结构时，没有人真正考虑过维护。它们看起来是不可摧毁的。在混凝土的早期，人们认为这是一种永恒的材料，
that wouldn't need any attention at all. And I mean, that's wrong. We know that it does need to be looked after. It does deteriorate. It does decay. But it can be hard to tell when concrete is decaying. If you think of brick and timber, the decay takes place on the surface of them. But with concrete, the deterioration is internal. Concrete deteriorates chemically from the inside out. Part of this has to do with the metal reinforcements that help hold up most concrete buildings. The rebar, well, it can rust and the rust eats away at the overall structure.
完全不需要任何关注。我的意思是，那是错的。我们知道它确实需要被照顾。它确实会老化。它确实会腐烂。但很难看出混凝土何时在腐烂。如果你想想砖和木材，腐烂发生在它们的表面。但对于混凝土来说，恶化是内部的。混凝土从内到外发生化学恶化。部分原因与帮助支撑大多数混凝土建筑的金属加固材料有关。钢筋（你知道的）会生锈，铁锈会侵蚀整个结构。
But Adrian Forte says tearing them down is not the answer. Because as soon as you tear them down, then you have a problem, first of all, with what you do with the detritus that's left. And secondly, you've got to replace them with something else and use up a whole lot more energy and create a lot more CO2 in building something in that place.
但阿德里安·福蒂说，拆除它们并不是答案。因为一旦你拆除了它们，首先你就会面临如何处理留下的残余物的问题。其次，你必须用其他东西来代替它们，并消耗更多的能量，并在建造该地方的东西时产生更多的二氧化碳。
They already used up all that energy when they were made. They're already there. We can adapt these buildings to make them greener and make them more appealing places to be by adding windows, for example. But basically, Professor Forty thinks we can all develop the capacity to love these concrete roots in all their hulking glory.
它们在建造时已经消耗了所有的能量。它们已经在那里了。我们可以改造这些建筑，让它们变得更环保，并通过增加窗户等方式使它们成为更具吸引力的居住场所。但基本上，福蒂教授认为我们都可以培养出一种能力，去爱这些有着笨重荣耀的混凝土。
Yeah, sure, people can learn to love anything. But, you know, as with any art form, whether it's opera or painting or literature, the more you know about it, the more you'll get out of it, the more you'll appreciate it. And this is especially true of concrete buildings. Architecture students appreciate them because they know that concrete actually requires a hell of a lot of skill and finesse to work with.
是的，当然，人们可以学会去爱任何东西。但是，你知道，就像任何艺术形式一样，无论是歌剧、绘画还是文学，你对它了解越多，你从中得到的收获就越多，你就会越欣赏它。混凝土建筑尤其如此。建筑系学生欣赏它们，因为他们知道混凝土在实际操作中其实需要相当高的技巧和精湛的手艺。
To do architecture in concrete is proof that you really are an architect. It's the test of being an architect. With a concrete building, every little detail needs to be calculated in advance. Concrete is wildly intimidating to work with. Once you pour it, there's no going back. With a concrete building, it's like the result of an immaculate conception. The whole thing is an integral monolithic whole and it has to be right. And aside from the interesting design challenges it poses, concrete itself as a material can be subtly beautiful if you look closely. You know, what we think of as just a monolithic, consistent, homogenous texture is actually really rich
用混凝土做建筑是真正成为建筑师的证明。这是对是否能成为建筑师的考验。对于混凝土建筑，每一个小细节都需要提前计算好。使用混凝土工作会让人感到非常畏惧。一旦浇筑下去，就再也没有回头路了。混凝土建筑就像是无瑕受孕的结果。整个建筑是一个不可分割的整体，而且必须做到完美无缺。除了它带来的有趣设计挑战之外，如果你仔细观察，混凝土作为一种材料本身就可以展现出一种微妙的美。你知道的，我们认为它只是一种单调、一致、同质的质感，但实际上它非常丰富，
and has a lot of interest when you actually go up to it and consider it. Sarah Briggs-Ramsey, the one I spoke with at Berkeley's Worcester Hall, did a year-long project traveling around the world looking at concrete buildings in Europe, in Asia, and South and North America. To create a global comparison of one material that I think is so sort of under considered. It's like the background of all the cities, but no one actually stands to look. We call the city a concrete jungle to talk about the artificialness of the urban landscape.
当你真正走近并细细品味时，会发现它充满了趣味。莎拉·布里格斯-拉姆齐（Sarah Briggs-Ramsey）是我在伯克利伍斯特大厅（Worcester Hall）采访过的人，她曾花了一年时间周游世界，考察欧洲、亚洲、南美和北美的混凝土建筑。为了对一种我认为被严重低估的材料进行全球范围的比较。它就像所有城市的背景，但实际上没有人会停下脚步去欣赏。我们把城市称为“水泥森林”，以此来讨论城市景观的人工痕迹。
But concrete can actually be a very natural expression of the environment. Concrete's color and texture can be dictated by local climate, local earth, and local rock. This is the Harvard Science Center on the Harvard campus, and it's got a very purpley, like a really pronounced purpley color, and that's the ground from the site. Concrete can also be an expression
但混凝土实际上可以是对环境非常自然的表达。混凝土的颜色和质感可以由当地的气候、当地的泥土和当地的岩石来决定。这是哈佛大学校园里的哈佛科学中心（Harvard Science Center），它有着非常浓郁的紫色，一种非常明显的紫色调，而那就是来自当地地基的土壤。混凝土也可以是对当地风格和习俗的表达，
of local style and custom, like how UK concrete has big thick textured chunks of rock, while Japanese concrete is very fine and flat. But the beauty of concrete architecture is all the better when you can just observe the buildings like pieces of sculpture without actually having to live and work in them, which brings in concrete's surprising ally, photography. Concrete looks good in photographs.
比如英国的混凝土有着厚重且粗糙的岩石块，而日本的混凝土则非常细腻平整。但是，当你能够像欣赏雕塑一样去观察这些建筑，而不必实际在其中生活和工作时，混凝土建筑的美感就会更上一层楼，这就引入了混凝土令人意想不到的盟友——摄影。混凝土在照片里显得很好看。
It provides this kind of neutral background. It provides a wonderful setting for people's skin tones, color of their clothes. Fashion photographers realized this first and then pockets of the internet started to appreciate these concrete buildings. There are lots of these blogs and so on which show a kind of extraordinary enthusiasm for concrete. Photography is allowing a new audience of non-architects to appreciate these buildings for their strong lines, their crisp shadows, and increasingly, the idealism they embody.
它提供了一种中性的背景。它为人们的肤色和衣服的颜色提供了一个绝佳的衬托。时尚摄影师最先意识到了这一点，随后互联网上的各个角落也开始欣赏这些混凝土建筑。有大量的这类博客等等，它们对混凝土表现出了非同寻常的热情。摄影让一群非建筑师的新受众能够通过这些建筑强劲的线条、硬朗的阴影，以及它们所体现的理想主义来欣赏这些建筑。
They represent a set of ideas about the state of the world and what the future was imagined to be that, you know, we want to preserve. We should remember what people were thinking 50 years ago. If we tear these buildings down, we will lose all of that. Architecture, whether we want to admit it or not, has a sort of shelf life. A time after which buildings fall out of fashion and then are allowed to fall apart. Back in the 1960s, Victorian-style buildings were considered hideous, falling apart, impossible to repair, and we were tearing batches of them down, all the while erecting big concrete buildings. But enough Victorians were saved that today,
它们代表了一套关于世界现状以及对未来想象的观念，你知道的，这是我们想要保留的。我们应该记住50年前人们的想法。如果我们拆掉这些建筑，我们将失去这一切。不管我们愿不愿意承认，建筑都有一定的“保质期”。在此之后，建筑会过时，然后任由其破败。早在20世纪60年代，维多利亚风格的建筑曾被认为是丑陋不堪、破败落后、无法修复的，我们当时正成批地拆毁它们，与此同时却在竖起巨大的混凝土建筑。但幸运的是，有足够多的维多利亚式建筑被保留了下来，以至于今天，
they are these beautiful, lovingly restored treasures. Brutalist, heroic, whatever you want to call it, concrete architecture now finds itself at a potential inflection point. Too outdated to be modern, too young to be classic. And a small but growing band of architects, architecture enthusiasts, and preservationists would like us to just wait a bit and see. Maybe with a little time and love we might discover some architectural diamonds in the rough that we just can't see right now.
它们成了那些美丽且备受珍视的宝藏。无论你称之为粗野主义、英雄主义，还是别的什么，混凝土建筑现在正处于一个潜在的转折点。它太陈旧而无法称之为现代，又太年轻而无法成为经典。一小群但不断壮大的建筑师、建筑爱好者和历史建筑保护主义者希望我们能稍微等待并拭目以待。也许只要有一点时间和关爱，我们就能发现一些目前还无法看清的建筑沧海遗珠。
That story was produced by Avery Truffleman back in 2015. 99% Invisible was produced this week by me, Roman Mars, along with Martin Gonzalez, who also mixed this episode, music by Swan Real, and Martín González. Cathy Tu is our executive producer, Kurt Kolstad is the digital director, Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Berube, Jason De Leon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivienne Leigh, Lashma Dawn, Joe Rosenberg, Kelly Prime, Jacob Medina Gleason, and Me, Roman Marsh, as I
这个故事是埃弗里·特鲁夫曼（Avery Truffleman）在2015年制作的。本周的《99%隐形》（99% Invisible）由我和罗曼·马斯（Roman Mars）共同制作，马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martin Gonzalez）也参与了制作并负责本期的混音，音乐由斯旺·里尔（Swan Real）和马丁·冈萨雷斯提供。凯西·图（Cathy Tu）是我们的执行制片人，库尔特·科尔斯塔德（Kurt Kolstad）是数字总监，德兰尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）是我们的资深编辑。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·贝鲁布（Chris Berube）、杰森·德莱昂（Jason De Leon）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、薇薇安·莱（Vivienne Leigh）、拉什马·道恩（Lashma Dawn）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、凯利·普莱姆（Kelly Prime）、雅各布·梅迪纳·格里森（Jacob Medina Gleason），还有我，罗曼·马斯，正如我
said before. The 99% Invisible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building, in beautiful Uptown, Oakland, California. I think all of us are on Blue Sky now, which is kind of like Twitter, except it's not supporting an unelected billionaire who's currently dismantling the government. We're also having a ball on our Discord server where you can join us to make Oscar predictions
刚才所说。《99%隐形》的标志是由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）创作的。我们是SiriusXM播客大家庭的一员，现在总部位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰美丽的上城区的潘多拉大楼，向北六个街区。我想我们现在都在Blue Sky上，这有点像Twitter，只是它不支持一个目前正在解体政府的未当选亿万富翁。我们在Discord服务器上也玩得很开心，你可以加入我们去预测奥斯卡奖项
and talk about your favorite architect movies. There's a link to that as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
并谈论你最喜欢的建筑师电影。那里有一个链接，包含了99PI的每一期往期节目，网址是99PI.org。这期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。